I started at Hillsdale when I was 16
years old I think that's one of the
reasons my parents were pleased to have
me at a small school close to home
everyone at Hillsdale immediately is
overwhelmingly kind and welcoming and
it's a family atmosphere from the
beginning and so I think that it's
probably one of the few colleges I could
have gone to at that time that would
have felt so safe I studied a lot in
college I think I might have studied
more in college than I did in law school
I grew up figure skating competitively
and so I trained like a full-time job
and I think that it was kind of natural
to approach college with a similar
attitude that if you're going to do
something you do it seriously I'm
grateful for that attitude I'm grateful
to my parents for putting up with all of
that growing up I think it was a gift to
me I was a Kappa which was great fun
several of my sorority sisters remained
dear friends to this day
after law school I clerked for two
federal judges one on a federal district
court and one on the United States Court
of Appeals for the Ninth Circuit when
justice Cavanaugh was nominated I went
to work in the White House counsel's
office to assist them I spent a lot of
time with the justice and I was
delighted when he asked I would be
interested in working for him at the
court after his confirmation clerking at
the Supreme Court is an incredible honor
it is a dream for many law students it
was for me there are only a few dozen
people who get to do it every year
Hillsdale is a very special place to
spend four years I would tell students
to appreciate the gift that they had in
the education that they're being offered
it is rare
take advantage of your professors take
advantage of the community and the
friendships that you can build at the
school and work hard don't take it for
granted is what I would say